- Jim Acosta was sitting 10 feet from me
and he badmouthed me,
saying a PR stunt that I
did, he blamed me directly,
a PR stunt to get to promote MyPillow.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and this is "The Rubin
Report Lockdown Edition."
Remember everybody, you
can get all of our videos
totally ad-free and
early at rubinreport.com.
Joining me today is an American
businessman, entrepreneur,
and founder and CEO of MyPillow.
Mike Lindell, welcome
to "The Rubin Report."
- Thanks for having me on.
- Thanks for taking the time, my friend.
I've wanted you on for quite some time,
and then over the last couple of weeks
you went from a guy
that's kind of hard to get
to a guy that's impossibly hard to get,
and now I've got you in a hotel
and we're gonna take
advantage of the time.
So everybody knows what
happened a couple weeks ago
with you at the White
House and the brouhaha,
and as I was saying to you off camera,
watching the media go
after you was so consistent
with what I've seen about
so many of my guests
who have dared to take
an opposition opinion
than mainstream allows for.
But I want to hold that for a little bit
because your backstory,
what you've been through in
your life is pretty incredible
and it's a true story of
perseverance actually.
I know you've told the
story many times before,
but could you just back us up
and tell us the Mike Lindell story,
and then we'll get to
everything happening in 2020.
- Absolutely, and by
the way you talk about
after I said that at the White
House, at the Rose Garden,
I've had over 80
interviews now since then,
so it's brought this platform
that God's given me to just huge,
and just when I think
it can't get any bigger,
it gets bigger.
You go all the way back for my story,
it begins back, I guess, with my new book,
"What Are the Odds? From
Crack Addict to CEO,"
but it takes me back to
I was seven years old,
my parents divorced,
and that's when divorces weren't common.
I got moved into a new
school two hours away,
and I was the only kid in the whole school
that was from a divorced family.
I felt like right away
it started manifesting.
I didn't fit in.
I would do things,
I remember climbing out
of a moving bus window
to show off and jump into the ditch,
we had snow in Minnesota luckily,
and everyone, they would go,
"Wow, can you believe he did that?"
with these crazy things,
or I wouldn't talk to them.
I was very shy in that respect,
but I thought in myself
that there's something different about me.
I just felt different.
I didn't fit in with any one group,
and this kept going on and
on throughout high school.
If I'd go traveling
anywhere, if I'd be anywhere,
I didn't even date really in
high school because of that.
It was just this unworthiness spirit
I think, when I look back now.
I was at my five-year reunion,
I worked the last two
jobs I had back then.
I worked for someone, I
worked at a grocery store
and a drive-in movie theater.
If anybody out there
don't know what that is,
it was a big theater where
you pulled up in our cars.
(laughing)
- I went to one drive-in
movie in my entire life.
I saw "RoboCop" in about
1989 or so at a drive-in.
- Yeah, it was a big thing
back when I was growing up.
I worked there for seven years.
It was voted the number one
place to work back then,
by the way, if you were to work
for someone, and it was fun.
But anyway, then I went
to college at the U of M
and the first quarter I dropped out.
I was still working the two jobs and that.
I just dropped out.
Right away, I was addicted
to compulsive gambling,
and I started drinking about 17,
actually late for 16 or 17.
We got to our five-year reunion
and I remember getting there,
and of course I was probably
high and been drinking,
and anyway all of these guys
had either started families,
graduated from college,
started their careers,
or they had kept the same job
and moved up the corporate ladder already,
so I was upset with myself
that I wasn't where I knew I could be.
Everybody was ahead of me.
I thought, "Wow."
But what I did is I took
over that whole reunion
and told them about all
these stories that were true.
I owed the mafia money, $20,000,
they came to break my
arms for football bets.
When I was 17, I got 18
tickets on a motorcycle
in two days outrunning the cops.
I went to go skydiving, fell
asleep on that motorcycle,
crashed it, was bound and
determined, it was all banged up,
and bound and determined to
get down to Stanton, Minnesota
and finish this skydiving
jump, it was my ninth jump,
and my parachute didn't open.
I had a streamer, hit the
ground, and all these things,
but I'm telling everyone at the reunion
and they're just going, "Wow, wow."
Well, I didn't hear
anything about anybody else,
but I got home that
night and I laid in bed
and it was just a deep
sadness came over me
that I really wanted what they had,
and I had fallen into this thing of like
where's my life going?
Well, then it was about 1982 or '83,
you know, I did different things.
Then I became a card counter,
a professional card counter.
My uncle, I worked on
his farm raising pigs.
I guess that was the last
job I had for someone,
and I decided, "Well, I'm
gonna raise pigs myself.
"Why am I working for him?"
So I went and bought
all these feeder pigs,
put them in a semi-residential area,
and the bottom fell out of the market.
That was a disaster.
But I tried all these
entrepreneurial things
on the same parallel track
as I had tried cocaine,
and when I tried cocaine it was instant.
I could be where I wanted to be.
I had this false courage.
It masked any pain I had.
I felt like I was on top of the world.
It didn't matter what
anybody thought of me.
I felt better about myself.
It was all these big lies,
but I was a very functioning addict then,
cocaine addict for 20 years,
until I switched to
crack in the early 2000.
But during that time, I
married the girl of my dreams,
I had four kids, a very
functioning addict.
Addiction affects everyone,
no matter how many forks you eat with.
People that say, "Oh, there
are addicts in the street,"
that's what they perceive an addict at.
Well, most of your
addicts, I hate to say it,
are functioning, they're
in the corporate world.
I was afraid of talking to anybody
that had a suit and a tie on,
I wasn't as good as them, you know.
But they had just as many
problems as anybody does.
Well, anyway, I was
always an entrepreneur.
I ended up having a bar for 13 years,
and that bar, probably a
bad place for an addict,
but I tried different things in the bar.
I learned a lot there with entertainment
and advertising and
stuff, different things.
A lot of the stuff I learned there,
I learned the entrepreneurship,
I really took up,
but it also was a bad
place for my addictions.
Then it switched to
crack in the early 2000s,
and then I could not do what I was doing
with the bar anymore because
crack's a different drug.
It's not a social drug.
You're tweaking out windows.
It took all my friends down
that were on crack very fast,
and I said, "I'm never
gonna be like them,"
and I ended up one of the worst ones,
if there is such a thing.
I had to sell the bar in 2003,
and that was a circumstance
beyond my control,
but it was going down anyway.
It was going down the
back side with the crack.
About 2004, in the middle
of the night one night,
I had a dream of the name MyPillow.
Now, I had always my
whole life searched for...
I had problems with pillows.
When I was 16 at that grocery store,
I actually went out and took
one of my first paychecks
and went out and looked
around at a department store
and bought a $70 pillow in 1977.
Who does that, right?
- That's a seriously expensive pillow,
adjusted for inflation.
- Yeah, you adjust it,
it was the most expensive
pillow I could find.
What's strange that I'd
buy a pillow way back then
to where I'm at now,
but I tried it, it didn't
work, I couldn't return it,
and I just remember that,
but it was an endless search for pillows.
Anyway, I had this dream
of MyPillow, the name,
and I got up and I wrote
it all over the house,
connecting the Y and the
P, and I'm all excited.
One of my daughters comes upstairs
about 2:00 in the morning,
she's 11 or 12 years old, she
goes, "What are you doing?"
I said, "I'm gonna invent this pillow.
"It's gonna be called MyPillow.
"What do you think of the name?
"It's gonna change millions of people.
"It's gonna be the biggest thing ever."
I didn't even know what
was gonna be in it yet.
(laughing)
She grabs a glass of water and she goes,
"That's really random, Dad."
(Dave laughing)
Then I went all in.
I kept getting these dreams.
What I wanted was
something you could adjust.
Me and my one son, for day after day,
he'd get home from
school and we would tear,
I think we tried over 94
different kinds of foams
and things to go in it.
Nothing did what I wanted it to,
but I just wouldn't give up on it.
My friends were laughing.
They're going, "Mike's gonna
invent a pillow, ha, ha, ha,"
and the other ones would say,
"Hey, if you ever come up
"with something like
that, I might want one."
Well, it took about a
year, year and a half,
and we finally had it done.
We had no money left,
but we had some pillows.
I took the first one, I went
into a Bed Bath & Beyond,
I remember going in there,
bringing it in and going,
"Where's your manager?"
They go, "He's over there."
I'm talking to him, I go, "Hey,
I got the best pillow ever.
"You can move it and it adjusts."
I didn't really know everything.
I said, "You can wash and dry it,"
but I'm telling him all this
and I'm so passionate about it,
"How many do you want?"
I didn't know anything
about retailer selling.
He goes, "We have one
buyer and he's not here."
I go, "Well, where is he?"
"Well, he's one national buyer."
I was so persistent
and passionate he goes,
"You need to leave now."
I go, "No, really, how many do you want?"
"Now." (laughing)
This is the way it went,
closed door, one after another.
Nobody wanted the pillow,
nobody wanted MyPillow.
Someone said, "Mike, why
don't you do a kiosk?"
I said, "How do you spell that?"
(Dave laughing)
I actually went to the kiosk
and I found out something there.
I was really out of my element
because I could be on
drugs, selling or being,
which one of the things too,
when I did sell a pillow
all those times, I never broke
trust with the promoters.
That's a key thing.
But anyway, so we rented this kiosk
in Eden Prairie, Minnesota,
and I couldn't stand it,
talking to people straight.
They'd come up and so it was just...
I was shy, it was just
like I couldn't talk,
and I'm actually hoping no
customers would come up.
It was kind of weird.
My wife at the time, she
worked most of the hours,
but the one day I did work,
the guy came up, very aggressive,
he buys one, he says,
"You got a business card?"
He said, "This is really unique.
"You invented this, you
got a patent on it?"
I said, "It's patent-pending."
I said, "Oh, I'm all out,"
and I wrote it on a piece of
paper, gave him my number.
I remember the kiosk being such a failure
and I ended up borrowing
money for Christmas presents.
We had our house mortgaged,
we had nothing left,
but we had 300 pillows and
that's all we had left.
Everything was gone.
That guy called around January
7th that year and he goes,
"Are you the guy that invented
this pillow in Minnesota?"
I said, "Yeah."
And then I knew it, I knew I
only gave my number to one guy,
and he goes, "Well, I run the
Minneapolis Home & Garden Show
"and I save a spot for
innovative products.
"This pillow, I've been sleeping
on it, it changed my life."
I'm going, "Wow."
I said, "Yeah, I'll come in,"
and I borrowed money to
actually get into his show.
But I got in there, then I put a table up.
I put a table out in front of me
so the people could come in the booth,
so I felt more secure,
like a security blanket,
and they came by.
That first day I remembered
I changed the booth
and I did the selling,
and it was easy for me then
because they were coming up
and I had an agenda.
I would tell them just X
amount, there was no smalltalk,
and they would go by.
Boy, I was selling them that first day,
every single one of them
almost I think that first day.
They came back the next day,
got back into the home show,
and told me, came up and said,
"Wow, this pillow did this
"and it helped me sleep," and all this.
It wasn't about the money for me.
For the first time, I felt so good inside
that I had done something
to help somebody,
and this ties in with
addiction and everything
which I can tell you in a minute.
But from that point on,
that started seven years
of doing home shows and
fairs, going town-to-town
throughout the Midwest,
then throughout the U.S.
We'd make them and sell them
at these home shows and fairs,
and just hours and hours of work.
And some shows would be good,
some shows would be bad.
But staying there on
track, with crack cocaine,
another addiction.
And then people were taking the company,
there were so many that were attacking,
trying to take the company,
that we'd have someone work for us,
there was different people, coming in,
they'd seen something there.
But I did get the patent.
But they would copy, they
were trying to copy it
and everything else.
We ended up making
pillows, it got to be 2007,
we were labeling them in our living room,
and I'll never forget looking
over at my wife at the time
and my son, one of my sons,
and I knew that it had gotten so bad
we were gonna lose everything
'cause these guys were taking the company.
The lights were gonna go out on the house,
we were losing the house.
And then my wife left about two days
before the lights went out on the house.
She couldn't take it anymore.
So I went through, got a
divorce, lost everything there.
The pillow was just a
little blip on the radar.
And then it got to be 2008,
and significant things happened in 2008,
but the pillow company
was just like a pulse,
like somebody in a coma.
And one of the significant things,
I was up 14 days with
no sleep in Minneapolis,
and I come out of the room,
and all three of the biggest drug dealers
are standing there, and I
go, "What are you guys doing?
"You know each other?"
And they go, "We know of each other."
And they said, "You've
been up for 14 days,
"you're not getting any more crack."
And I said, "Is this an intervention?"
And the guy goes, "Call
it whatever you want."
Well, two of them left,
and the other guy said,
"How much you got left?"
I showed him how much rocks.
He sat down to make sure that
I did it and went to bed,
wasn't getting any more.
Well, he finally fell
sleep right about the time
I was running out and I was tweaking
and looking on the floor,
carpet colored farming,
looking for crack.
There never is crack there.
Well, I went back downstairs,
headed outside at 2:30 in the morning,
and it's like bees in every
inner city in the country,
you can get crack and you can get drugs.
You're out there like bees.
It's like a whole nother world.
And I'm out there offering
money, $20 for a $5 rock.
Nobody would take it.
They're looking at me
like, "What are you, crazy?
"We're not selling to you."
They had threatened anyone on the street,
if you sell to him, we're
gonna kill you, or who knows.
Well, I came back upstairs
defeated, walked in there,
and the dealer says, he says,
"How'd that work out for you?"
He says, "Give me your phone,
I'm gonna take a picture."
And he took a picture, he
said, "There's for that book
"you've been telling us about
you're gonna write someday."
And he goes, "Man, you've
been telling us for years
"that this MyPillow is
just a platform for God,
"and you're gonna come back someday
"and you're gonna help us all out
"of this addiction world that we live in,
"and we're not gonna let you die on us."
I was their hope, 'cause I
told them that all the time.
Here's the actual on my
book, the actual picture.
It goes into a hologram.
You see the bad picture there?
- [Dave] Unbelievable, unbelievable.
- I put that on there,
so that was the picture
taken in 2008, and then to where I am now.
And by the way, two of
those guys work for me now.
They're born-again Christians
and none of them sell anymore.
So it's come full circle.
But that year, my son was
crying in the driveway.
He had got back from a hunting trip.
He's all teared up, he was 18, he said,
this was another place
where you're in a losing...
I said, "You coming in?"
He goes, "No, dad, I
can't live here anymore."
I thought I was hiding it from him.
And I just said, I'm quivering
'cause it's breaking my heart,
and I said, "Yeah, you can
go live with your brother,
that's no problem."
And it just hit me, like you
ain't hiding it from anybody.
And then this guy came in December,
this is really key to my
Lindell Recovery Network
when we talk in a minute,
my friend came in December.
There was nothing left.
I was sitting in the
house, everything was gone.
Dick comes walking in.
I go, "Dick, what are you going here?"
Now he was my equal, we were the same age,
we both started cocaine at the same time,
very functioning addicts,
both switched to crack
about the same time, and he
had quit four years earlier
and found the Lord.
And I heard about that,
but here he shows up,
and I go, "Dick, what are you doing?"
And he goes, "The Lord led me here."
He goes, "What's going on?"
I go, "Well, as long as you're here,
"I got questions for you."
I said, "First of all, is it boring?"
He goes, "No, man, it ain't boring."
And I drilled him for an hour.
I drilled him for an hour,
because you know what?
I respected his answers because
he's been where I'd been
and he had made it through somehow.
I call it my hope match in my book.
Well, a month later, I end up quitting.
On January 16, 2009, I prayed
and I said, "Okay, God."
There was nothing left.
I made sure I didn't have
any money or anything
so they say it was at your bottom.
It wasn't really my bottom.
I think I could have
survived without money,
but I knew if I went one more day,
I would have two courses on my life.
One would be my calling,
where I'm at today,
and if I went one more
day, that would be gone.
It would be whatever reel B would be like,
like an old drive-in, whatever
the second feature would be,
wherever that path was taking me,
that's where that was going.
So I prayed, I said, "I'm
gonna wake up in the morning
"and never have the desire again."
And I woke up in the morning,
and all the desires were gone.
Now, I did go to a faith-based
center about two months later
to find out why I was an
addict in the first place,
but then things started
happening, that these miracles...
These guys had taken the
company and took all my shows,
and I needed $30,000.
I met this guy, this is just
a story I tell all the time,
this guy said, "Oh, I have
some guys that'll take a chance
"and borrow money or whatever,"
and I talked to him a
couple weeks earlier.
I meant to meet him, I needed
the money, in the afternoon,
30 grand, and I was walking
in there with a tee-shirt,
and here I walk in, and I don't
know these guys from Adam,
here's a CIO, a CIEO, a CFO,
they're all wearing suits.
I'm scared to death.
I go in there with a pillow, and I go,
"Hey, you guys, I wanna borrow 30 grand.
"I'll pay you back 40
grand within two months.
"I'm gonna set up shows.
"I'm gonna have the biggest,
"it's gonna be the biggest
company in the world someday.
"These guys took my company.
"I used to be a crack cocaine addict."
And one of the guys said,
the CFO I think it was,
"Well, when did you quit crack?"
And I said, "Last Thursday."
(laughing)
Literally, four of them
got up and left the room,
and it's like "Shark Tank,"
for that reason, we're out.
And the other four ended
up giving me the money.
- Wow.
- They got zapped.
They never checked my
ID, 'cause I knew that,
'cause I didn't have a driver's license.
So I walked out of there with the cash,
ended up paying them back,
but things like that kept
happening for the next two years.
I got up to when I did that, I
said to my friends and family
we had no money left again, and I said,
"You guys, if we all put in money,
"I have a dream of the
biggest infomercial ever."
"If no box store is gonna take
us, nobody's gonna take us."
Because everybody that bought
it at those shows loved it,
and people would tell other people.
So they put their money in,
and we were told by these
professionals, going,
"Oh, infomercials don't work.
"It's just to get into the box stores."
I said, "Well, the box
stores don't want me,
"and I don't wanna go there.
"I'm gonna do it my way."
And they said, "Oh, it won't
work, you need an actor."
And I said, "I wanna do it
like I did at the shows,
"with a real audience, make things real."
The infomercial launched at
3:00 a.m. on October 7, 2011.
I was living in my sister's basement.
Everything I had was
banked on that infomercial.
And it aired, and I had 10 employees.
Now we had just phones
that we were taking,
everybody taking phones
up, my friends or whatever,
and within 40 days we had 500 employees.
It just exploded.
I built my own call center.
We were hiring people off the street.
They go, "Mike, you need to be CEO."
I go, "Why do I need to be CEO?
"Let's make pillows."
They go, "We need an HR department."
I go, "That sounds horrible."
"We need a corporate attorney."
I said, "That's even worse."
(Dave laughing)
And we never missed a
beat, we never missed a...
Everybody got their pillows on time,
MyPillows on time for Christmas.
But it just went (blowing air).
- All right, there's so much there,
but I wanna focus a little bit on the fact
that it seems like you found your purpose
in the midst of on absolutely
chaotic time in your life,
sounds like personally, family,
obviously the drugs and the rest of it.
When you look back now,
do you think you needed
all of that craziness to
actually find the purpose
that now is clearly
having you live the life
you're supposed to be living?
- Well, absolutely.
You see me wear my cross
on TV all the time,
and I even wear it when
I didn't have it on TV.
I would always tell my
friends after the bar closed
back in the day, I would tell them about,
"Hey, I read about Revelation in the Bible
"when I was in jail."
I'd be witnessing to them.
I didn't have God or the
Lord, a personal relationship.
Those guys would quit that day.
28 people quit during those years,
and my friends are going,
"What are you saying to them?
"We're losing friends."
Well, it was all those times,
'cause I had 14 near-death experiences
that would run through my book.
I had things that only you go,
that in the book it's
like what are the odds?
When you have a one in a million happen,
a one in a billion, or you
push this off just to chance,
when you add them up in your own lives,
when does it become a miracle?
For me, I used mathematical
odds that God has to be real
because all the stuff that
happened to me was impossible.
My actual day that I did a
full surrender, get this,
(phone ringing)
it was February 18, 2017.
That's just a few years ago.
But I always had faith,
but I didn't have...
To answer your question,
everything that happened to me,
I say it all the time, I
would not change one thing
if it's not where I'm at right now,
because that convinced
me that God was real,
and I just turned it over
to him full surrender,
and now I can go out and use my platform.
I don't have any worries,
I put all my faith in God,
and I can go out and do these things,
my evangelism, things to help people.
That's what I do.
This wasn't about selling a pillow.
It always has been MyPillow was
the platform, and that's it.
- You must have had
people from the outside,
probably lawyers, PR
people, the rest of it,
that must have been saying to you,
"Mike, the pillow is great and all,
"you can keep selling them,
"but you probably shouldn't
talk about the story that much,
"the crack that much, religion that much,"
the other things that clearly
are the drivers behind you.
But did you just ignore
those voices all the time?
And I'm sure you still hear them now.
- Yeah, here's a good one,
this first started happening
when I wore my cross on TV.
I was up in Canada on a shopping channel,
and I was all by myself,
all lonely or whatever,
and it was just like I said, I
still had that thing going on
where I couldn't talk to people
and I'd rather be alone at that time.
Anyway, I was breaking
every record they ever had,
and all of a sudden, here's
somebody, a lady shows up,
and this is a 24-hour
thing, it's grueling.
You get to sleep for like five hours.
She walks in my room and she goes,
"Hello, I'm your executive producer,
"and congratulations,
you've broken every record
"here in Canada, but I
need you to take your cross
"and tuck it in your shirt or take it off
"for the rest of the time you're here."
And I looked at her and I
said, "And why is that?"
And she goes, "That's religious,
"prejudice against other
religions," or something like that.
And I just went on a rant.
I still had a little anger issues then,
and I just flipped out, 'cause
I wanted to leave anyway.
It was like the movie, "My Cousin Vinny,"
when the gal wants to say,
"You're right, goodbye."
(Dave laughing)
I go, "You're right, I'm outta here."
I said, "That cross is staying there,
"so either you like it or not."
And she stopped and she goes,
"Well, if you feel that strongly about it,
"I guess you can leave it on."
This is the thing I fought with that,
people used to call me
when I was the only person
taking phone calls, doing
them home shows and stuff,
and I did a little
public access TV station,
and people would call up and say,
"You're wearing your cross on
TV," and they'd be atheist,
they'd even be Christians
slamming me for it.
It didn't matter.
I would argue with them.
It wasn't about selling a pillow then.
I'm arguing with them and telling them
things in the Bible again and
things that happened to me
that couldn't have been
any other explanation.
They would find Jesus and hang up,
and I'd go, "Take that,
how do you like me now?"
And I'm still unsaved.
(laughing)
And then it manifested, it's funny,
I'll skip ahead, I gotta tell you this,
now when they say boycott Mike Lindell
and boycott MyPillow on the
trolls and bots on Twitter,
the other people say all the time,
"Don't boycott him."
He goes, "He'll double his ads.
"We see enough of that guy."
(laughing)
- When we get in a little
bit to what happened to you
after the Rose Garden speech,
that was an interesting moment
because I saw a ton of that.
The media's going after you,
and then you look at what
regular people are saying
and they're like, "Yeah,
I just bought a pillow,
"I just bought a pillow."
People are screenshotting
receipts and the rest of it.
But I wanna talk a little bit more
about the business specifically,
because the idea that you
did the on-air infomercials
and that sort of thing,
and that you still do them,
it's like there's something about them.
The amount of times that I've
watched your infomercials,
or I remember growing
up watching Ron Popeil,
"Set it and forget it,"
all of those things, that spray hair.
For some reason, even if you
weren't gonna buy those things,
you watched them.
There was something about them.
Do you think there is some
sort of magic to that,
beyond just being yourself
or whatever Ron had?
What is it about them?
- I think God's given me this platform,
and for me, for my gift from
God, to be able to speak
and to have that, that's
my calling to be that.
That's beyond anything I'd ever imagined.
But one of the things
is we make them real.
We do all our own commercials.
We have other companies,
we tell them what to do.
It's just me and a couple of
my people inside MyPillow.
We make them real, and it's an anomaly.
No products have made
it sustainable on TV.
Every time you see a MyPillow,
it either breaks even,
that one, exact one, either breaks even
or makes a little bit,
'cause I don't need the
other stores and stuff.
I did something that's
never been done before
where you're directly to the consumer,
directly to the public.
One of the things is I think
it's the realness of it,
and I've been on TV now 2.8 million times.
I heard that number, I
had to fact-check it.
I'm going, "What?"
To me, it's beyond
anything I've ever seen.
But once again, that platform,
to get that platform of trust
and of realness, it's
just this is who I am
and I'm not gonna change,
and I'm putting it right out there.
That's why you won't see
one of my commercials
where I'm not wearing that cross,
and people like to see what's
real, and it transfers over.
I am who you see on TV.
I'm not something different
that's all canned.
Most of the things you
see, like the one back in,
the man in the mirror
one time over by the bed,
we had one whole day of
taping where I'm over there
with that couple in the man in
the mirror, that commercial,
and I'm holding it, and I go,
"You're gonna wake up in the
morning and (screeching)."
We just left that natural stuff in there,
and people would see me on the streets,
and they'd go (screeching).
(laughing)
The jingle's so powerful,
too, that was cool.
- Well, it's just so obvious also
that you were ahead of the curve,
because now because of podcasts
and YouTube and everything else,
almost everything in the digital space
is direct to consumer, right?
Everybody's often using code
Rubin or whatever it might be
to sell their products.
So you, through going deep on television,
you actually helped model something
that now really works online, too.
- Well, it depends what
you pay for the online.
It's just like a TV ad on TV.
I'm very blessed all of a sudden
that I could never put any ads on CNN.
I'll say this straight up.
I couldn't put any ads there
because they were still
charging for a bigger viewership
from back in the day, so it
didn't matter what I did.
But just recently, I was
able to break even on them,
so I'm putting them right...
And here I got of their hosts
saying bad things about me,
and all of a sudden my
commercial comes up,
hello, I'm Mike Lindell,
how are you doing,
wearing my cross, and there you go.
That's pretty cool.
- That's about as good as it gets.
Okay, so let's talk about the CNN host
and what happened over
the last couple of weeks.
So obviously, we're in
the middle of coronavirus,
President Trump gives a
speech at the Rose Garden,
updating people on what's going on,
as he's been doing pretty much every day,
and then he brings you up.
Well, first he sort of told
people what you were doing.
But you know what, I'll
just tee it up to you.
I'll just let you tell the whole story.
What's that morning like?
Did you know you were
going to the Rose Garden?
- I wanna bring everybody back here.
I wanna bring it back in time.
You have to know that the
part where I quit everything
and how did I end up with me being friends
with the president of the United States?
I think to have that, you kinda
grasp what happened there.
When I quit all my drugs and everything,
by the grace of God, I had never voted,
I didn't know a liberal
from a conservative.
I didn't know a Democrat
from a Republican.
I knew nothing, and I didn't even care.
Politics didn't affect me.
That's what I thought,
but when I came out of crack
addiction and everything,
it was like coming out of a coma.
I look around and I go,
"What's going on here?"
My friends are all unemployed,
they're losing their houses,
I'd already lost mine.
We got a president giving
money to an evil empire.
We got half-time of baseball
tournaments for Little League
and they're giving out
first-place trophies to everyone.
I go, "What is going on?"
I mean, everything had changed.
I'm going, "This is crazy."
Well, anyway, then you get up to 2016,
I explain a lot more in my book,
but I get invited by Donald
Trump before he was president
to come to New York City to Trump Tower.
I get there, a private
meeting, on August 15, 2016.
Now, I walk in there and
it was just him and I,
and he goes, "Mike, do you
always wear your cross?"
I go, "Yeah, Mr. Trump, this
is a divine appointment."
And for some reason, I wasn't nervous.
I go, "Wow, he's a normal guy."
And he started telling me
all these things about...
They had told me, "Whatever you do,
"don't tell him you're
an ex-crack addict."
That's one of the first things I told him,
"And by the way, I was
an ex-crack addict,"
and I got him when he had
big platform for addiction.
And he goes, "I wanna wipe out the drugs.
"I wanna build a wall,
they're pouring in."
He told me about how he
wanted to bring jobs back
and manufacturing back here
to the U.S., like MyPillow.
And he asked me questions about that.
I mean, I'm going, "This
guy, wow, he really cares.
"He has no agenda other than
he cares about our country."
I had been everywhere from
people who eat with four forks
to no forks, and I'll tell
you one thing I learned
in all those years of being in that bar.
I could judge character,
and I'm telling you,
he was just genuine, it was amazing.
I walked outta there a half hour later,
and I go, "He's gonna be the
greatest president in history."
I went to his employees
'cause I couldn't believe
what I'd just seen, talked
to so many of employees.
I want everyone to listen to that.
Every one of them said great things.
I go, "Is this real?"
He goes, "Oh, he's the best boss.
"He helped me out personally."
It was every one, same thing, same thing,
from a doorman to a
clerk, it didn't matter.
Now I go back, and I want
everyone to hear this,
I go back to Minnesota
and I tell my board,
I said, "You guys,"
this was right in the
heat of the campaign,
I tell my board at MyPillow, I
said, "You won't believe it."
I said, "He's gonna help this country.
"I've never seen anything like
it, it's gonna be amazing.
"And I wanna do a press release
"and I wanna go telling people on TV."
Back then, I could tell the media
that I'm walking across the street,
20 cameras would show up.
(Dave laughing)
But anyway, my board said, a
member, my corporate attorney,
he goes, "If you do this,
you're gonna ruin our company."
I got mad and I went outside the office,
and my CMO came out and she goes,
"We didn't get this far by
you not listening to God."
I go, "You're right."
I went back in that boardroom and I said,
"We didn't get this far by
me not listening to God,"
'cause I felt it was my
calling, that I had to back him,
that it was something I was
divinely supposed to do.
And so I did that press release.
Now, I didn't even tell
them what we talked about.
You would think the press would be,
"Wow, a Minnesotan, just random guy
"that has a great story
about being an addict,
"that now he's gotten salvation,
he's gotten redemption,
"and he got to meet what
could be the president."
You know what?
None of them called.
But some of them did contact
me, they called me a racist,
they called me everything
you could think of.
The Better Business Bureau in Minnesota
took MyPillow's rating
from an A plus to an F.
- Wow.
- 'Cause I ran my buy one,
get one free too long,
because that's their own little internal
whatever, bars.
They're a pay-for-play
business, they're not a bureau.
Anyway, and then the lawyers
in California tapped me.
They went after me for all kinds of stuff.
- Had you ever experienced
anything like that?
I mean, you had had your
own trials and tribulations,
but had you ever seen just by, oh,
saying I'm gonna support
this guy or I like this guy,
to watch like a machine go after you?
- No, nothing like it.
I could compare stuff back in the day.
You know, I've had swords to my throat,
I've had guns to my head, you
read my book, I've had it,
it's all happened to me.
But something like this,
where you're going,
"What did I do?"
It's like I couldn't believe it.
And then you're trying
to destroy my dream,
this dream we had gotten so big,
and you're trying to destroy
it and all my employees.
That was my hurt.
I go, "They're gonna kill
us, all my employees."
I had probably 800 employees
or 1,000 employees at the time,
and they're just attacking.
We were in the news.
All of them would come
up, even every newscaster,
when the BBB took me
from an A plus to an F,
every news outlet in the country,
I was the story of the year,
and that was like January 2, 2017.
Every news was out
there, it didn't matter,
ABC, NBC, CBS, CNN, it didn't matter.
And they're just slamming
me and soundbiting me
and making me look terrible.
So I learned fast there.
Right away I said, "I'm
only doing live interviews,
"'cause you're not gonna
take it and chop me up."
But I've gotten used to it.
I actually now, it's over,
once you get past that,
it's too late to close the gate,
the cows are outta the barn.
I am growing stronger
and I'm not changing.
You can sit there.
Over the past couple of years,
every time they say something wrong on Fox
or do something there, or not wrong,
but say something that they don't like,
they'll go, "Boycott
MyPillow and Mike Lindell."
That's when they say, "Don't boycott him,
"he'll double his ads."
Well, like I've told them before,
I advertise across the
board on every station.
If I had to pick and
choose what every host says
on cable TV, they go, "Oh,
that's subjective there.
"You know what, I'm not gonna put an ad
"on you right there."
I've had CNN and MSNBC
badmouth me directly,
and I still advertise.
I keep it separate.
I enjoy the fight.
- Not only that,
you've also doubled down
when boycotts have come on
for certain hosts, right?
When they were really going after Tucker,
weren't you the one that filled the gap?
- Filled it up.
Back with Laura Ingraham,
she was the first
big boycott that they
did, and we ran my ad
right at the start of the hour
and I just filled it up with MyPillow ads.
I was the only one
basically for a while there,
because I couldn't believe
it, what they were doing.
You're trying to tell me and
you're telling my employees,
let me see...
You never see their faces
either, the hidden ones,
other than hosts that'll say stuff.
But here's what happened though last week.
So we got a little rerun here.
I never thought that my popular fame
could go any bigger, whatever,
infamous fame, whatever you wanna call it,
but I start making masks.
I converted my whole company,
75% over to making cloth masks,
and it was quite a project.
We had to train all the employees,
but we did it in like four days.
- Can you just explain a little
bit about how you do that?
Did you have to bring in
experts to change machines?
- I made a call.
I made a call to the
vice president's office,
actually an email, and
they sent me right away
to Peter Navarro and
whatever he was running,
and I didn't know who Peter Navarro was,
and then he emailed me right back,
and he directed me to a task
force they had already set up
and a little coalition
about anybody that was...
All these different
things, from masks to gowns
or whatever, kinda like let's set this up
so people can have their
questions answered.
So I called them and the
first question, I said,
"What are the measurements?
"Is there a restriction
that I have to know about?"
'Cause obviously I have to
worry about getting sued
by frivolous lawyers in
California, let's not forget that.
So, I had to make sure
everything was right.
In the meantime, I already
said I'm doing this,
so my employees, they're
very good at scaling.
I've had some of the same
team, we're like a big family.
We just started going.
We took the sewing machines, moved them,
made them eight feet apart.
We had to move racking.
Then I had to make sure that
we had the right fabric.
It was a blessing, the MyPillow
fabric was perfect for it.
We just had to not do two processes,
printing and another thing.
So we had to do a different process,
but it wasn't a big switch.
And then I had to get elastic.
At first, I bought the wrong elastic.
It had latex, so I had to dump
that, get the right elastic.
There was a little shortage for one day,
but I was determined I was gonna get it.
And then we had a really
expensive cutting machine
so we could cut the patterns.
And we were up and making
masks in three days.
Everyone was trained.
- Incredible.
I think we made close
to 10,000 the first day.
We added two shifts.
A friend of mine, 'cause a lot
of them had to be laundered
at a commercial laundromat.
I was up till 12 every day
setting the foundation,
till midnight, starting
again at five in the morning.
Well, then I get an email from
the vice president's office
and said, "Could you come out
"and be involved in a roundtable?"
I was involved in one in 2017,
first time I was ever in the White House,
and for Made in America.
And they said, "And we'd like
you to write some remarks."
And I'm going, okay,
they gotta get approved.
I'm going, "What do I need remarks
"for a roundtable for?"
So actually, the remarks are here.
These are the typed ones here.
These are the typed remarks, okay?
So I type them up and send them out there,
and I wasn't even real particular.
They wanted remarks of what we were doing
and specifically about
what MyPillow was doing.
I'm going, okay, I don't really...
That's fine, I don't
really need to brag about
what I'm doing to help the
country, but I'll do it,
it sits in a roundtable.
So I fly out there, we
get to the roundtable
and all the five CEOs that are there,
the vice president, a
couple guys down at the end,
I forget who they were,
and we go around the table
and each one, well, this
one's doing respirators
and this one, I said, "We're doing masks."
But I wasn't looking, nobody
was looking at their remarks
or whatever, I didn't
even seen any papers out.
So then the president came in
and it was a good half hour
of everyone saying what they're doing.
You guys, can you make more?
What are your plans?
We get done, and the president
gets up and they all get up,
and I said to the vice president, I said,
"We didn't read our remarks."
He goes, "Oh, no, no,
they're for our outside.
"The president might call
you up to the thing."
And I go, "Really?"
So now, we go into the other
room towards the Oval Office
and the president, he was
showing the other CEOs,
kinda giving a little mini tour here,
and then he sits down and
he's gotta read his speech
with the vice president.
And we're sitting over
there at this table,
and I thought, you know
what, I'm reading the remarks
and I go, you know what,
I wanted to give a message
of hope to the people.
So I start writing on the back,
and if you can see my scribbles,
there's little arrows
that go down and stuff,
and when I wrote it, I
thought I would rewrite it
on a clean piece of paper.
I just get done with the last thing,
I mean, there's crossed
out and everything,
and they go, "Okay, we're
going out to the Rose Garden,"
and I'm going, "What?"
I'm going, okay, so all I said was,
"God, please let me read my writing."
(laughing)
It turned out the president
calls me up first.
I came right up, we didn't practice this,
so I didn't know we were
all gonna go around the end,
so he called me up first,
and I went straight up,
so I think they held the other CEOs back
so it was just him and I.
And here's a guy that has so
much nervousness of speaking,
now I did, my throat, I
had vocal cord surgery
just a week before, so I was
a little raspy like I am now,
and I get up there and I read them,
and then I just felt led, and
I turned around and I said,
"Mr. President, do you mind
"if I read something off the cuff now?"
He said, "Yes."
And then I read that God gave
us grace on November 8, 2016,
and just read that and talked about
that the nation had turned its back on God
and we should spend this
time reading the Bibles,
getting back in the Word,
and spending time with our families.
And I said, "We're all
gonna get through this
"with this great administration
and everybody's prayers,
"and everybody combined, and
we're all in this together,
"and we're gonna be stronger
and safer than ever."
You have have think I'd shot somebody.
(laughing)
- Okay, so you do all
this, it's impromptu,
he's letting you do your
thing, you talk about God,
you're making I think at one point,
you were making 50,000 masks a day, right?
Yeah, you're doing that right now.
So you finish the speech, and
did you even think about it
or realize what was
about to come your way?
Did it even cross your mind?
- No, do you know what, it was like to me
it didn't feel like...
I didn't think it'd be a
shot heard round the world.
We went back into the White House,
and the first inkling I got
that it might be real big
was the vice president
came to me, and he goes,
he was just, "Wow, Mike."
He goes, "You've opened up the heavens.
"I mean, people are gonna, you're just..."
I don't even remember what he said,
but I could just tell he just loved it.
I'm going, good, I got
a little confirmation
that it was okay.
The president never said a thing about it.
He was talking to the CEOs and us.
When I left the White House, I finally,
you got my phone back, see
they have your phones, right?
And I open up my phone and turn it on,
I had 750 text messages.
I didn't know that many
people had my phone number.
- Dear God.
- And I'm going,
"What had happened?"
I looked at Twitter and it
was just (robotic whirring).
I looked at my Facebook, it had blown up.
I had 2,000 emails, and
I'm trying to drive,
and I'm going, wow, I had to pull over.
I'm calling friends,
I go, "What happened?"
They go, "Don't you know,
everybody's talking about it."
And I'm going, "Really?"
So from that point, I've
done 80 some interviews
as of today, every day, all day.
I've gotten calls from Israel,
my friends in Australia,
they said it was on top of all the news.
In the Taiwan paper, it was the cover
of their national paper.
This was like you'd think it was...
One of the good things there
is I'm glad I asked the president,
because everybody knew he had no idea.
He had no idea, so people that said,
"Oh, you're mixing church and state,
"or church and God, or whatever,
God and the government,"
you know what, I did that,
so what are you gonna do,
put me in jail, sorry.
- Right, well, the government
didn't force anyone
to listen to you.
People could either hear you and believe
or enjoy what you say, or not, so be it.
Okay, but now talk about
just the media reaction,
'cause I'm sure you're
getting a lotta love
from nice quarters, and it must be nice
to hear the vice president
say some nice things,
but really, I was watching
it as it happened on Twitter,
and the amount of mainstream media people,
who've never donated a dollar,
given up any of their time,
they're, "Oh, the MyPillow
guy," mocking you,
mocking Trump for bringing you on,
it's a big stunt, blah blah blah.
Meanwhile, you're the
one, I mean, it cost you,
you don't have to tell me how much,
but I assume it cost you quite a penny
to convert the operation.
Not only that, but what you're
then not making in pillows,
and the rest of it.
- Oh, absolutely.
That was God's way of rewarding me
for just speaking out his name,
because now when that happened, everybody,
we had laid off a bunch of people
that were on the road doing home shows.
I have 90 some people that
do home shows and fairs,
like I used to do, they
had lost their jobs
because they're closed
and my stores were closed.
Well, now they could all get,
(phone ringing)
they could all get on phones.
- The calls are still coming in.
- [Dave] Yeah, they're still coming in.
(laughing)
But they could get on phones
now and our business went up.
Like you say, for every one attack,
nine people, it's even more than that.
I think for every one attack,
50 people would go after that guy.
What's wrong with you?
They would tell that guy,
"What is wrong with you?
"He's doing great things.
"What have you done?"
And these hosts on MSN...
Jim Acosta was sitting 10 feet from me,
and he badmouthed me saying
it was a PR stunt that I did.
He blamed me directly,
a PR stunt to get to promote MyPillow.
Are you kidding?
Maybe you didn't listen right, Jim.
I was promoting Jesus,
I was promoting Bibles,
and spending time with our families.
He got it a little wrong there.
Maybe he didn't listen.
Maybe he only listened to
the first part of the speech,
which every CEO went up
there and talked about
what they were doing for the country,
and Jim, what are you doing?
These were the things that was like...
And then I went on all this media,
but it was a good thing because
I was on a lot of media too,
I was able to take the politics out of it,
we're all in this together.
I don't care if you're a
Democrat, Republican, liberal...
It don't matter, I went
on all these outlets,
from "People" magazine
to the "Washington Post,"
Fox, I mean it didn't matter.
The actual outlets treated me right.
I mean, they actually treated me right.
It was these hosts, late-night hosts.
One late-night host said,
"We got Mike Lindell
"coming on tonight from MyPillow.
"He's gonna talk about
absolutely nothing."
And "Saturday Night Live,"
of course, they did their...
Alec Baldwin did his, the mess he is,
he did his mocking.
So what I say is this, and
I told the president this,
I did tell him this.
I said, "You know, Mr. President,"
I said, "these press
releases that you're doing,
"or these press conferences,"
I said, "people are seeing
how a great leader you are."
His ratings up 60 some percent.
But I said, "I wanna read you something."
I said, "This guy is a friend of mine
"and I've known him all my life,"
and I said, "he sent me
this text, and it said,
Mike, you know I'm not a
big President Trump fan,"
he's a never-Trumper is what he is.
He said, "But you know
what, God bless him.
"He's doing a champion of a job.
"I think he's turning me."
And you know what, what's
happening is the whole country
is coming on board and they're gonna see
that having a pragmatic,
common-sense president,
who's an information vacuum
cleaner takes it all in.
What other president would take and listen
to private sector people,
listen to his governors,
listen to everyone,
before he makes decisions.
It's amazing having a businessman.
I don't call it the Republican Party.
He's changed it to the commonsense party.
If I had to look at
politics before he took in,
there's things in that
party I didn't like.
He's divined a whole thing,
this is the way it should
be, for the people.
And I wanna tell everyone out there, too,
that when I left the
White House that night,
I had more...
I'm an optimist like you wouldn't believe,
but I'll tell you what, it
went from here, level two,
to level 10, the highest it could be,
because you know what, I
was seeing the same thing
I've seen before, he was
making a decision here.
Some governor, it would
have took him six months
to do something, he did it in four days.
He said, "Let me take care of that,
"let me take care of that."
We have somebody that's making decisions
not based on politics.
He's in the back there, he
goes, "We need to save lives,
"but we need to get people back."
It's the biggest decision, he
said it the other night, ever.
Well, you know what, you gotta know this,
every politician, and
most of them I've met,
and I've met them on both sides,
these career ones that are out there,
they've all their lives
they've made decisions
with their own agenda it seems like,
and they don't have the people's back.
And finally, this is what's changed.
And even people on the left,
I don't care if you're a
liberal or whatever you are,
you're seeing that this
is the commonsense thing,
because this president
knows problem/solution,
but he's got a God-given talent
to know what it's gonna manifest to,
to help each and every one of us
bring joy to our daily lives, that's it.
- So as a guy that went
from an optimist to now,
you can call it a super optimist,
in the midst of a this craziness,
and clearly you're loving life right now
and things are good and you're
still producing the masks,
as you just said, you had
a certain luxury in that,
because you're successful,
and not that they couldn't
have taken you down,
but you had a bit of a cushion
there to weather a storm.
What would you say, 'cause I
get this question all the time,
I get this from college students,
that they're afraid if they say one thing
that goes against what mainstream wants,
that they are gonna get destroyed,
what would you say to a young person
that wants to stand up, but
doesn't have that cushion
or even a family that's gonna defend them
or worry that they're gonna lose their job
or the rest of it?
- Well, you know what,
we're getting through that.
If I just gave you advice
three and a half years ago,
I would have said, you know what,
if I'm you, I'm scared, too.
I'm me, and I don't ever
back down and stuff.
But not I say, you know what,
it's happening all around you.
Now they're the small voice.
We have to all rise up and be that voice.
You speak out, your
business will be busier
if you speak out for what you believe,
and you don't back down to evil.
And you know what, when I said that,
about God being taken out
of our schools and colleges,
I meant that.
These young people are looking for hope.
Right now is the time of the
greatest revival in history.
We have people out there looking for hope,
looking for something to grasp onto.
What's wrong with Jesus?
What's wrong with faith?
And if you're an addict
and you're at home,
I wanna bring this in, too,
because that's what my
book is with my addiction,
if you're an addict and
you're at home right now
and you can't even get out, whatever,
you're in quarantine or whatever it is,
you know what, everybody knows before this
massive deaths we were having from heroin
and from fentanyl and
stuff, it's horrific.
But you know what, we all know that.
Now if you're a 22-year-old
opiate addict or heroin addict,
you also know one of your friends
that made it through your own age,
just like I told you about my
friend, Dick, that came to me.
Now's the time to pick up that phone
while you're sitting there
and reach out to that guy,
and say, "You know what,
how'd you get through?
"How'd you make it?"
Ask him those questions you can't get
in a treatment center,
ask him the questions.
That's who you need counseling you.
And on the opposite end, if
you're somebody sitting at home
that's made it through,
had your hearts restored,
you probably went to a
Salvation Army, Teen Challenge,
Union Gospel, a faith-based
treatment center that works.
The secular ones' success rate,
I don't even wanna get into it.
They're just to take our insurance money,
and it's horrible.
But anyway, if you're someone
that's made it though,
now's the time to reach
out to people you know
that haven't made it yet,
they're still on drugs,
they still need their hearts restored.
They have wounds, maybe
they were fatherless
or went through a divorce
or never had a father,
like affected me in my life.
Addiction comes from
childhood fatherlessness,
wounds, trauma.
Anyone that tells me,
"Oh, it's a disease,"
I don't believe it.
I've seen it too many
times where this happens
and it manifested into using
an addiction to mask pain.
Reach out to those people,
and we'll make it the biggest AA meeting
in the history of the United States,
only we'll use Jesus as our higher power,
not just some made up higher power,
and it'll be amazing.
This is what I want everybody to know.
We're gonna get through this,
and when we get through it,
we're gonna be just like 9/11.
9/11, we were safer and more secure.
If 9/11 hadn't happened, it's
horrible that it happened,
but you know what, we were
so vulnerable to terrorism,
and now you go into an
airport, you go into arenas,
and you're checked, the
metal checks and everything.
Well, now when we come out
of this, it'll be different,
but we'll be protected
against an unseen evil
for a long time to come,
and I guarantee that this president,
what he's been saying all along,
let's bring our manufacturing
back to the USA,
but let's bring the ones we
don't have to rely on China,
our medical devices, our medical
things we need to survive.
- I got only two more for you, Mike.
(Mike laughing)
Is there anything that
you haven't accomplished
that you want to accomplish
beyond just continuing the message
that you're trying to get out there?
- Well, when this gets over with,
I'm launching the biggest,
it's called the Lindell Recovery Network.
It's not gonna help just 5,000 a year,
it's gonna help millions.
I can't even tell you how it works.
It works somewhat like that
hope match I talked about.
I've been working on it two years.
I have millions of dollars
of my own money into it.
It's gonna bring millions off
addiction, I'm not kidding.
This is the most amazing platform.
I believe it's right from God.
It's a divine thing.
My book, what I'm doing now,
my book, I even bought my own paper,
I printed three million copies.
I self-published.
You know why?
'Cause I didn't want any middleman.
You're not gonna find this out in stores.
I'm going direct to the people
because I'm taking proceeds,
and this is what's gonna work,
what's gonna help the Lindell
Recovery Network get launched
to help millions of people and employ
tens of thousands of ex-addicts
that have gotten their hearts restored.
Let me tell you about addiction.
I'll tell you one more
thing about addiction.
You know why I have so many
ex-addicts that work for me?
I'll you, people say to me all the time,
"Mike, you work so hard,
you need to take a break."
You know what, I don't work
hard, I love what I do.
Addiction's hard work.
Any addict knows that we're
the hardest workers ever.
When you're an addict, you
gotta just to get the drug,
all the things you go
through, and you know what?
You get that person set free
and they're gonna set the world on fire.
They're the hardest workers,
it was great entrepreneurs,
these great minds,
and it's amazing.
So that's one thing I'm doing,
and where the platform
leads, I don't know.
I've spoke to big stadiums,
50,000 people stadiums,
for a guy that couldn't talk.
U.S. Bank Stadium in Minnesota,
I spoke to 50,000 millennials.
I did about a 10-minute
version of my story,
and they had Christian bands
and they had big evangelism speakers.
From the people I've talked to,
probably hundreds of the
people that were there,
it was my story that resonated with them,
and that's because people wanna hear
it can only be in America, the USA,
a story where here's a crack addict.
And I'll tell you this, in 2017,
when I walked into the White House,
the president invited me to a meeting
of the USA Manufacturers Summit,
and I remember seeing a
picture, I was a big Elvis fan,
a picture of when I was a kid of Elvis
shaking hands with then
president, Richard Nixon,
and I thought, wow, Elvis
got to see a president,
to be next to a president.
It wasn't about Elvis, it was about,
wow, he got to be with the president.
I walked in the White House
and guess what's on the wall?
That picture!
And I'm going, wow, and
it's surreal for me.
And I walked in and I
get back to this room,
we're having this roundtable,
and it's surreal for me.
Here's this ex-addict.
I sit down and my name tag's there,
and there's no name tag next to me.
I said, "Who's sitting here?"
He goes, "The president is."
Now he came in and we sat
down, and on national TV,
here's me sitting next to the president.
All my friends that have seen that said,
"There is no way this crack addict
"is sitting next to the
president of the United States.
"It can only be God,
because this isn't real."
For me, it's like I don't know
where the platform's gonna end,
but I think we're in the greatest revival
in the history of the world.
And I just take that we
are gonna bring our country
back to God, people back to God,
because when do people
look for their faith?
And they look for it when times are bad
and because they need to get through,
and that is the hope, and
that's what I'm doing.
My calling, wherever God
leads me, wherever that...
And I did know by this,
when people have asked me,
"Well, Mike, do you wanna run
for governor of Minnesota,"
and all this stuff, I don't rule that out
because you know what, I
do know that politics now,
that I didn't know before,
play more of a role
in our daily lives than anything.
Everything they do in Washington
affects what we do daily,
and I never knew that before,
and I don't think a lot
of people know that.
They go, "Oh, that's
just a bunch of people
"that argue back and forth."
No, it's not, it's real, and
we're going through it now.
I'll just give one last little thing here,
how it affects daily lives.
That network I'm setting up,
the Lindell Recovery Network,
do you know there's 30 some states
that have laws on the books
that you cannot counsel an addict
unless you went to school or
to college for four years,
swam the English Channel,
climbed five trees,
did three back flips, all this stuff.
I'm going, are you kidding me?
Do you know who I want?
That person had never been an addict.
Do you know who I want counseling me?
I want the guy that's been
there and made it through,
and that's it.
I had to get around all that
just to launch my network.
I mean, these are things that block
things that could be so
good for us every day.
That's where I'm at.
I wanna get rid in this country,
one of the things that I'd
like to do, the corruptness.
You've got the social
media, the platforms,
you've got the Googles,
you got the lawyers in
California suing for nothing,
all these things going on.
An entrepreneur in our country,
they can invent something,
it gets taken right away.
I'm setting up a thing, this
is another thing, mystore.com.
It's gonna be a safe
platform for entrepreneurs.
Anybody copies one of my entrepreneurs,
I'll never sell that place a pillow again.
There's a lot of things I've got going.
- Well, Mike, I gotta tell you,
as an interviewer, I know
when someone's phoning it in,
and I know when someone's
telling the truth
and living what they're
supposed to be doing,
because I can literally
feel it through the screen,
and I think my audience can as well.
So I've loved chatting with you,
and obviously we'll continue
this on many fronts.
And good luck out there, and
you've stood up to the mob,
so you're already good to go.
- I love it, bring it on, bring it on.
God bless you.
- Thanks so much, Mike,
appreciate it.
If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist,
and if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.